and speaking of kyler murray that leads
off what you need to know this morning
because steve keim the gm of the
cardinals who really didn't say much
about the whole what are they going to
do with the first overall pick in the
draft and what are they going to do with
josh rosen the quarterback they took
10th overall after trading up in 2018
steve keim had this to say recently
about kyler murray and the trade that
sent josh rosen to miami you have to
make the tough decisions and avoid the
outside noise why'd you give up on this
guy why would you trade this guy it's
unprecedented i took rosen in the top
ten i just felt that murray was a
generational talent that i just couldn't
pass up my first reaction when i saw
those quotes coming out now courtesy of
the ringer.com chris
they didn't call him a generational
talent until they saw what he could do
in a pre-season game yeah right they
wanted they wanted that that little
confirmation that that extra little
solace that comes from being sure that
this guy does translate at least from
the standpoint of the eyeball test to
the nfl now you can call him a
generational talent before let's not get
too far ahead of ourselves and even
though they still are too far ahead of
themselves at least they waited to see
what he looked like in uniform on a
field throwing a football with nfl
caliber players on the other side of the
line of scrimmage yeah that's right i
mean if he said if he said this and uh
kyle or murray went out there and was
one for nine with an interception uh
that wouldn't look right so he did he
probably wanted to wait to see a little
success on the field to make those type
of comments publicly but i truly believe
them that's how he felt privately and uh
of course you know with the addition of
cliff kingsbury uh we we know how highly
he thought of kyla murray so i'm sure he
had cliff in his ear too going i mean
hey this guy the first time i ever
talked to cliff kingsbury about kyla
murray was at the nfl combine and his
eyes lit up he's a freak i mean that's
what he said to me right off the bat and
i knew right then that oh there's a
chance kyler murray might go to the
arizona cardinals but mike you've been
saying it you said it before the draft
you you just can't pass up on a guy like
this it's it's you know i'm not saying
it's patrick my homes but it's patrick
mahomes-ish in theory
because we've never seen guy do some of
the things he can do already and what he
did in college
and what we were saying before the draft
isn't that he is a generational talent
what we were saying is
it's better to assume that he will be
yes and be wrong about that than it is
to say ah he won't be and let pick
number two pick number three pick number
four whoever be the team that gets the
guy who is the generational talent and
then it's in your face for the next 15
years unfortunately for a team like the
browns i mean they they had they had
done that with uh
passing on carson wentz when they could
have had him and they could have had
patrick mahomes they could have had
desean watson right and once they got
baker mayfield that kind of wiped it
away but the cardinals would have been
in a tough spot if they hadn't taken
kyle murray and he becomes a great
player so now they can say the g word uh
because they've seen him play but still
there's a long way to go before we
conclude that kyler murray is truly a
generational talent i mean andrew luck
was supposedly a generational talent and
we're still waiting for his specific
generation to produce the results that
the colts were hoping for seven years
ago chris yes uh i mean he's had a few
bumps in the road but even with that
we've seen enough to know okay when he's
healthy he's certainly special you know
maybe he's not patrick mahomes uh but
but still you know the playoff
appearances his ability to be clutch in
the fourth quarter always brings this
team back to give a chance to win the
ball game uh if they're stuck in that
type of situation yes but he's dealt
with injuries but but to what you're
saying you're exactly right i mean
that's the thing if kyle murray went
somewhere else uh and had success and
started to show some of this
generational talent that would have been
the fastest way for steve kaim to get
fired uh get on the bad side of michael
bidwell because he would have been like
what the hell did you do how did we pass
that guy up and uh hey i give steve come
a lot of credit i really do it took guts
to make that type of decision and he did
it and we'll see how it plays out but it
certainly looked good after preseason
game one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports